the q's powers do they come from
technology or biology
welcome to scitrek your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
[Music]
i've always wondered where do the q's
powers come from
now we know very little about the origin
of the queue what we do know we actually
have to infer from what he says and what
other queue entities have said and what
we see them do
so
it's an angel argument and one that i'm
probably going to get really a lot of
crap on the comments for but
is the queues powers based on technology
or is it something that they evolved
i'm going to say straight up
it's technology
i don't believe the q's powers could be
evolved they're too magical and i don't
like magic in sci-fi
and i do have an argument that backs up
this
so
the first time we ever see the queue
we see that ball of energy that um that
field that actually then has to chase
and then and captures the enterprise
why would cue have to do that if his
powers were really omnipotent and
unlimited
if his powers are really godlike he
could have just clicked his fingers and
shut the engines down but in case
instead he had to chase them
now you could say and you could argue
that that was all part of
basically the game he was playing that
he was actually trying to scare the
humans and and trying to make them feel
weak but the fact is he still did it
that way
so it does seem to feel like that that
was some sort of technological
capability rather than a god-like click
of the fingers and and just manifest his
will into reality also there's there is
all the clicking and the eye gestures
and the things like this there seems to
be gestures required to sort of activate
the powers
why is he clicking his fingers why is
there a big flash of light all the time
unless this is some sort of activation
process or something that
is required for him to focus his psychic
energy say or his mental energy on to
activating the process
it seems to be that all the q have that
little hand wave all these hand gestures
that are required for the powers to work
and that reminds me of the trelani
character who obviously might have been
a cue
anybody that says he wasn't you can't
really say that so from the original
series the square of gathos we saw this
character trelani now he
had many many a similar characteristics
to the queue
he also had seemed to be similar powers
they had the power to transform energy
into matter and matter into energy
without any real problem they had
mastered that
something that gave them god-like powers
but we know trilani's powers were based
on technology the mirror that became
broken and we saw the tech behind it
other people have argued though that
actually trilani isn't a cue because his
parents turn up at the end of the
episode his parents basically come and
tell him off for what he's been up to
but i would actually argue that we see
similar things to that with the queue
for example the episode deja queue in
the next generation where q is punished
for his naughty behavior and sent to the
enterprise without his powers he is
stripped of all his powers now the
council that we see repeatedly in
episodes saying like like q squared
later where and we see q junior for the
first time and you have the the the
judging panel come across very much like
parents they come across very much like
the characters do in the original series
episode with trilani i would argue that
they are very similar but there's also a
big problem that the q are actually a
species exist out of time so
triangle could have been a far earlier
version of the queue maybe and maybe
before their powers had sort of evolved
a little bit further maybe before the
continuum existed
because once the queue got to a point
where they sort of exist out of time
you never know what you're actually
coming in contact with you could come in
contact with a far later far older queue
before meeting a far younger queue
don't exist in a linear time like we do
they can jump around through time frames
really as much as they like
we don't know when the queue could have
evolved there is one theory that q is so
interested in humans because actually
humans become the q eventually and that
is them coming back to try and move us
along that path that's not a theory i
actually subscribe to i don't believe
that you are i believe the q are a
species or maybe a group of species that
evolved and became this later but if you
think about arthur c clarke he always
said that if we came in contact with an
alien species if it was sufficiently
advanced enough technologically we would
not be able to discern the difference
between that technology and magic
i believe the queue are very similar i
think they have
merged with that technology that they're
actually potentially maybe even a hybrid
that they were maybe have some innate
abilities because we do see species with
abilities that we would consider almost
magical like psychic troy for example is
a beta zed she has psychic empathic
abilities we've seen other species that
have very much godlike powers but we
again don't know that they could be a
version of the queue themselves there is
also a point though that if the queue is
technologically based why haven't we
seen any of that technology through some
of the other episodes well maybe we have
the guardian of forever is a gateway
that is appeared in many brilliant
episodes including actually one of my
favorite episodes from discovery
it's
when spock and kirk asked it what are
you are you technology or are you a
being he basically said i'm neither i am
my own beginning and my own end
it felt like
q-type technology maybe that was a
technology built by the ancestors of the
queue before they ascended up into the
continuum what that object was capable
of
is something that we see with the queue
it seems to be something that the queue
would use
perhaps that is a relic of the queue
before they ascended up to the continuum
i also have to wonder though as well why
are the queue so bothered about the borg
they obviously sent the enterprise d out
to
make contact with the borg as a test
but also then in again the voyager
episode with q junior
q junior brings a couple of ball cubes
right on the doorstep of voyager janeway
is about to get assimilated when q
appears
he grabs hold of q junior and throws him
down and says if we've told you once
we've told you a thousand times you
don't antagonize the borg
why
why is he so bothered about antagonizing
the borg now a lot of people would argue
that they wouldn't be interested in the
book they can click their fingers and
make them all disappear
but they don't
why
maybe
the q are interested in keeping the borg
at bay because at some point in the
future they could the borg themselves
could become a threat to the queue
if the queue is technologically based
even though that technology might be way
beyond anything we can actually imagine
the borg could get to a point where
similarly how they moved into fluidic
space they could maybe try to get into
the continuum space
but maybe if there is a species that
could adapt to the way the queue work
and the technology the queue use the
perhaps the borg are that
and that even though the ball going to
threat at the moment in our time frame
in the next generation time frame
that they could become a threat in the
future
so antagonizing them
and
bringing attention to yourselves as the
cue maybe might not be the best idea
there is also the basic argument that
actually even though the q say they have
godlike powers
they obviously don't
they are repeatedly surprised
in the next generation
um gainan appears up from behind the bar
queue doesn't know she's there and is
surprised to see her
he also then is about ready to get rid
of her and geinan seems to be ready to
defend herself
now i would argue that gainan
was doing that because maybe she knew
she could defend herself
even when q
is in the voyager episodes he doesn't
expect voyager to be there he's
surprised he actually says you you are
supposed to be here for another hundred
years
he doesn't seem to have god like paris
because he is constantly surprised again
is that because his powers are
technologically based and even though
they are amazing
they're not unlimited i would also argue
that actually
the queue threatened to wipe out mankind
that is the basically what they're
threatening to do at the start of the
next generation series and again at the
end i don't think they actually could
though
they might be able to go back in time
and stop us from ever evolving
but can they click their fingers and
just wipe us out of existence
the problem with that is i don't think
they actually have the power to do that
and it is why they don't
like in the same way that the next
generation level of technology like the
replicator would seem like magic to us
today
that the q technology seems like magic
just because it's far enough advanced
that we don't understand it
please leave a comment tell me what you
think is the q's powers godlike
omnipotent born with evolved whatever
however you want to put it are they a
being with that energy or is it
technology-based or is it perhaps a
hybrid a mix of the two
and if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification it really helps me out um
you can join the channel please there's
a link in the description um and give a
small amount of money a month it really
helps me to create more content i don't
have to rely on the youtube pennies in
and you can also join us on facebook
again a link in the description
please guys
leave a comment tell me what you think
and stay safe i'll see you next time
[Music]